illness is a a universal human condition
everyone at some time in their life
needs healing this was of all others the
most important place to bring your
problems if you would come in ancient
times you would have passed as you can
as a tourist today through that
propylaea that great gate you would have
entered a vast sanctuary perhaps one of
the biggest ones in Greece in fact it
included within it an entire stadium and
area for athletic games it had one of
the largest theaters in the Greek world
a spot that will be the climax of our
visit and it also had places sacred to
the healing God escalade pious where you
would spend the night you would sleep
hoping that a dream would visit you
hoping perhaps that one of the sacred
snakes of escalade pious would slither
up out of its underground lair and bless
you by licking your eyebrows or in some
other way
granting you physically that healing
power you may have wondered at times why
the emblem of a doctorate of Medicine in
today's world is a herald staff little
wings on it with a couple of serpents
coiled around it it comes from this cult
of escalade pious where serpents served
that heroic God as the means the
physical visible means of transferring
healing power from the God to the
afflicted person these serpents
apparently lived in a circular building
called the tholos follows Thol OS that
simply means a circular building in
greek and they serve many different
functions the tholos in the Agora at
Athens is for instance a dining hall and
meeting area for counselors for a
representatives of the Democratic
government who will spend night and day
in that place so that whatever disaster
may happen at whatever hour there's
someone there on duty to respond the
tholos in Delfy has been excavated we
still don't know what its function was
but we do suspect that the follows there
at Epidaurus that circular building is a
place where the sacred snakes live down
inside the crypt area and you can still
see rings of stone masonry between which
the snakes probably lived and received
food from above given to them by the
priests of Aesculapius pilgrims with
their ailments didn't sleep in the
tholos itself it appears that a large
rectangular building whose foundations
are still visible adjoining the tholos
area they went there to sleep and hope
that the snakes would somehow come
either spiritually or physically to
visit them and grant them dreams that
would indicate how to cure them or
simply magically through their touch
cure their ills
[Music]